hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich stehe heute wieder neben
severin in der küche und zwar bin ich
gerade in frankreich war letzte woche
mein video gesehen hat weiß dass ich
gerade ihnen vogesen bin und ein paar
tage in frankreich verbringen durfte
weil der firma dbm und mit severin
zusammen habe ich ein paar französische
spezialitäten schon zubereitet und heute
geht es war es ganz tolles da wurde mir
schon richtig davon geschwärmt und vor
gesperrt und ich hab selber noch nicht
ausprobiert aber wir werden bis heute
zusammenpacken und zwar machen wir keine
late model genau was ich das also die
kernel module kommen aus die stadt woche
und ich ist eine typische form die
historische aus kupfer gemacht ist weil
für diese rezepte braucht man eine sehr
gute wärmeleitung um ein sehr gute kam
die xerox abend der ganz frauen ist also
nicht außen per amelia kinder in die
backform ist außen aus kupfer und innen
wird sind ja genau und der nachteil ein
bisschen von
der sinn der tränen ist dass das geht
weg also meine sache im jahre 1998 haben
wir gesagt wir möchten gern silikon back
matten entwickeln und wir haben ein ziel
als wärmeleitung das ist kupfer wir
möchten wirklich denn
also dass das silikon genauso wärme
leitet wird wer mich kennt weiß
eigentlich mag eigentlich nie in silikon
backformen weil also ich kenne das von
meiner mama die hatte früher das war
bestimmt vor zehn jahren schon hatte sie
die ersten silikon backformen und hat da
drinnen marmor kuchen gebacken also
marmorkuchen ist ein ganz typischer
kuchen und also den gebacken hat und der
eine dreiviertelstunde im backofen war
hat einfach die ganze wohnung nach
diesen silikon gestunken
und der kuchen der wahrheit also
normalerweise kennt man ja die sind ganz
normalen springform wo man den namen
drin backt und da wird das schön außen
knusprig innen weich und saftig und da
drin war aber irgendwie wieso gummi also
der hatte keine schöne kruste und
deswegen war ich schon immer gegen
silikon bank formen und auf der messe
auf der ambiente habe ich dann letztes
jahr bei db diese backformen gefunden
und severin wird es mich heute
wahrscheinlich von der bak frau
überzeugen
also ich bin ja immer noch skeptisch
aber wir werden das ausprobieren
ok also das besondere hier ist da ist
also dann wenn mit silikon muss also es
gibt sehr viele kleinen poren drin also
in die mischung das ja hilft die
wärmeleitung okay also mit diesem metall
und auch darin ein bisschen metalle für
die wärmeleitung sony verbessere also
das ist patient präsentiert
nur hier sind die einzelnen in der welt
die dieses produkt erstellen und wir
haben unsere eigene rezept von silikon
ja und die sind natürlich in frankreich
und jetzt noch kurz fragen sich
wahrscheinlich auch meine zuschauer kann
leer heißt ja auch diese form order
dieses gezackte ja das heißt doch dann
kommt der name oder kanäle kann und
darum ist der kuchen kann uli und wurde
jeweils auf produkt-know-how ja gedacht
kann durchaus worden was dazu gelernt
also wir haben gestern schon mal den
teig angesetzt denn ja teig muss über
nacht im kühlschrank ronja und wir
hatten nur eine zutaten nicht drin
unserer war dass das war den extrakt
hatten wir gestern nicht da mache ich
platz reichte also natürlich muss man
die silikon button auf
referierte backblech legen sodass die
wärmeleitung wirklich über die dass die
wärme gut durchkommt ja alles wegen
dieses backen
ok und wenn es flach ich gibt es so zu
viel kontakt also am besten die
kanalisierung der besser und dann sehr
viel luft das ist zirkulieren ja ok muss
ich das jetzt vorher einfetten oder wird
es jetzt direkt so benutzt ja das ist
das wenn man das kauft also nur ein
bisschen waschen dann das kann direkt
und mit die rezepte von genesis keinen
sinn wo das prinzip also wir haben das
jetzt ja schon vorbereitet aber in
meinem nächsten video zeige ich euch
natürlich schritt für schritt wie man
den teig herstellt und dann noch mal
eben alle tipps im video
ok das einfüllen dafür hat er ja
natürlich
wenn jetzt willst du sie bis drei
viertel okay
und dann musste trike im ofen ja so hoch
klettern wichtig sehr gespannt denn ich
habe das wirklich noch nie gegessen
aber ich kann mir das richtig gut
vorstellen dass eben draußen die kruste
schön karamellisiert den ofen haben wir
bereits vorgeheizt auf 230 grad ist es
ober unterhitze oder heißluft ein
luftloch durch
also wir stellen die jetzt in den
backofen und zwar bei 230 grad für zehn
minuten genau genau und zwar braucht man
jetzt diese hohe temperatur damit außen
der teig schön karamellisieren kann und
dann schalten wir runter auf 180 und da
packt 130 minuten ja okay das machen wir
jetzt kurz und in der zwischenzeit nehme
ich euch jetzt mit in die fabrik und
zeigt euch einfach mal wie diese silikon
formen hergestellt werden denn das habe
ich mir natürlich zuerst gefragt und
habe mir das ganze mal angeschaut
er hat mir jetzt gerade erklärt wie die
maschine funktioniert und zwar werden
hier diese silikon formen hergestellt
eine ahnung hat es gemacht ich schaue
noch mal kurz zu und dann bin ich dran
ich bin ich dran die frau wurde jetzt
bereits schon gemacht ich sage ich aber
gleich mit die nächste nehme ich hier
erst mal die überreste raus jetzt haben
wir die fertige formen die software
height 115 grad um genau zu sein
jetzt muss man das aus nur noch weg
schneiden und in der mitte den stoff
und hier außen und wenn jetzt immer so
ein paar pflanzen und den wir mit dem
cutter weg als auch hier haben wir
nochmal ganz schöne handarbeit
dieses rates flüssiges im rhein und zwar
wird es in einem separaten raum mit dem
metallpulver vermischt und kommt dann
eben hier in die maschine und wissen
form gepresst beim telefon gibt es zwei
verschiedene arten einmal das günstige
industrielle silikon und einmal das
hochwertige telefon was zum beispiel
auch in der medizin verwendet wird das
heißt dieses silikon ist daneben auch
für die gesundheit unbedenklich
das wird hier verwende deswegen sind
diese backformen auch etwas teurer aber
der preis nicht gerechtfertigte matthias
hochwertigem silikon es ist unbedenklich
und daneben auch für den hausgebrauch
geeignet
die kanäle borderlinx hier noch auf
dieses pack rost gelegt das ist ein
überdimensionales bacchus für diesen
backofen
denn dann werden die silikon formen noch
mal ausgepackt und zwar deswegen damit
einfach die dämpfe noch mal verschwinden
die werden dann bei 200 grad zwei
stunden lang gebacken und dann haben wir
das telefon ausgebacken ist es für den
hausgebrauch geeignet und bei dickeren
produktionen also bei willikens silikon
wird es oftmals nicht gemacht das heißt
der entwickler der kunde hat dann mit
silikon zu hause und sobald er das erste
mal damit packt wird es eben zu hause
aus gebacken und das ist eben nicht so
gut für die gesundheit
gäste
die formen hier die wurden jetzt ganz
neu gemacht und frage gibt es die auch
sonst gar nicht das sind rührschüssel
mit einem silikon boden und damit ist
einfach nicht auf der arbeitsfläche
rutschte kennt es ja wahrscheinlich wenn
ihr etwas früher dran sind dann backen
die schüssel immer hin und her und hat
man das einfach nicht früher immer so
ein geschirr untergelegt damit ins
wackeln
hier hat man die silikon beschichtung
des haftet ein schön auf der oberfläche
und man hat hier auch die skalierung
demonstriert genau wie viel manchmal
habe ich gerade in der rührschüssel
richtig toll
und er hat gesagt dass es jetzt mehr
neuheit also das ist die erste vor die
gerade hergestellt wurde und ich glaube
ich frage ist einfach mal auf ich eine
mitnehmen darf
ich bin jetzt auch wieder da vom band
mitgebracht okay aber das stelle ich
jetzt kurz zur seite nehme ich mich
einfach mit so tief sind fertig gebacken
ja hast du ein bisschen abkühlen müssen
ja weil und waren wirklich heiß kann man
die schöne karamellisieren gesehen habe
ist ganz toll ja die farbe ist ganz toll
und die die formel ist wirklich die
dieselbe als als die andere
ich bin gespannt
vielleicht können wir das schneiden und
dann probieren
ok es hört sich so an
also hier sieht man die gute kandidieren
man sieht aber auch das ist sehr saftig
ist deren drin ja also nicht
ausgetrocknet und ja da muss die
kanalisation stabilisierung und
entschuldigung
sehr schnell fertig sein
deswegen ganz wohl da muss es ganz
schnell deswegen providencia okay sonst
jetzt trocken und moral
ich kann das nicht geben weil es zu
lecker schmeckt lecker als er von der
konsistenz her sind sie wirklich außen
richtig knusprig ich hab so ausgeprägt
ist eigentlich nie gegessen und innen
drin
richtig es ist sehr locker aber dennoch
sehr froh euch also als hätte man es in
sirup noch mal getrunken
richtig lecker und ich finde es war
einfach mal schön zu sehen wie diese
form hergestellt wird
ich nehme dir auf jeden fall mit und
werde das rezept nochmal schritt für
schritt ganz genau euch verfilmen und
zeigen die silikon schüssel nehme ich
natürlich auch mit und der moral ist
aber auch sei begeistert ich habe so was
noch nie gegen uns ja auch wie so
knusprig aus nur hindernis so weit ist
der wahnsinn
richtig lecker das schmeckt wie purer
karamell und dann irgendwie wie ein
kuchen also echt so eine mischung aus
allem
seneca vielen dank für das tolle rezepte
und ich hoffe euch hat der einblick in
die fabrik gefallen ich hoffe euch
gefällt auch dieses neue rezept morgen
bekommt die wege sagt das genaue rezept
zum nachmachen und wenn ihr gerne mehr
solche rezepte und einblicke in fremde
kulturen fremde töpfe sehen wollt dann
schreibt mir einfach in die kommentare
also ich fand es schön bei dir vielen
dank dafür vielen dank
ich denke ich sehen uns bald wieder
komplett und bald wieder okay kein
problem
ok danke also bis zum nächsten mal
wahnsinn